[Music]
i think it was a historic week in
politics yeah yeah i'll tell you why it
is official it was official a few days
ago but it bears repeating arizona has
elected the nation's first openly
bisexual congresswoman i think that's
yeah
it's true
yeah she's already promising to reach
across the aisle and grab whatever's
there
doesn't care
i can't believe this story the man who
got a romney ryan tattoo on his face
said he is totally disappointed with how
the election turned out
yeah the man said he hasn't been this
disappointed since he got that [ __ ]
stamp for the movie john carter
a decision yeah
new research just came out this is crazy
it reveals the closer you live to a bar
the more likely you are to become a
heavy drinker
yeah
and the closer you live to a dunkin
donuts the more likely you are to become
the governor of new jersey
that's just a fact
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
big breakthrough for scientists
scientists have created synthetic
plastic skin that can heal itself
yeah
the synthetic skin is being called
revolutionary by doctors and the perfect
christmas gift for bruce jenner
he's got a
it's got a bit of a face
a issue of work done
this story's a little weird but check it
out a prison inmate in oregon who shot
his own jaw off
has demanded that the state pay for his
surgery
at least that's what i think he said
i just did i couldn't
[Applause]
[Music]
he shot his jaw
i'mma gonna go to hill when i die
remember that old classic i love it i
used to sing that on the late night show
whenever i tell a joke and i'm gonna go
to hell when i die ah another don't clap
the lawn
the nice thing is when i go to hell this
crowd will be clapping me today
look at him
look at him go
because i have a pretty good pictorial
representation
here we are yeah
writhing in the flames
sure is hot
you look terrible andy
according to an uh new research by the
journal of sexual medicine
size does matter when it comes to
pleasing a woman in bed
that's true yeah yeah the study doesn't
bother me i just don't understand why it
had to be cut out of that magazine and
then taped to my refrigerator
i'm gonna be sadder up close it's even
sad
wow
it's clear you believe that joke
it's funny because it's so not true